hi everyone Sal Khan here for our daily
live stream and just as a reminder of
what this is for some of y'all who might
be new is as we've as the school
closures have kind of rolled out around
not just the country but the world we
realized that there's a lot of demand
for folks to also feel a little bit more
connected to each other and there's just
a lot of information going around around
the school closures there's a lot of
materials that we're putting out and it
would be nice to have a place where we
can all connect at least once a day to
make sure that we can answer each
other's questions and get some of those
announcements out and so we're calling
this something of a national or global
homeroom and the whole point is to ask
your questions I have a fellow team
members who are looking at the questions
you're asking on Facebook and in YouTube
and on Twitter and we will get to them
and we're also going to be bringing in
some guests now one thing I do like to
remind folks is khanacademy is a
not-for-profit we are funded by
philanthropic donations it costs a lot
more money than you might think to
create a platform that can serve
hundreds of millions of people kind of
kind of is much more than me we're over
200 full-time employees thousands of
volunteers just our server costs are
many many millions of dollars and it
looks like our traffic because of school
closures is 2x and approaching 3x of
what it normally would be so we
definitely need your help I want to do a
quick thank you to some corporate
partners who have stepped up very
quickly to help us fund some of that gap
although we need more help from from
donations of all sizes but special
thanks to Bank for America 18t
google.org and Novartis who have been
some of the first to step up and but we
need more help from you and from others
now
the focus of today's livestream is
actually how do we help teachers and
parents get set up so that they can help
their students we've been talking about
that pretty much in every livestream so
far I've talked about these webinars
that we've run in the previous few weeks
we've talked about some of the resources
we've put out like the daily schedule
all of this is available if you just go
to Khan Academy
org you'll see a on our home page you'll
also see a little banner regardless of
where you are in Khan Academy org that
will point to some of these resources
Peter of professional learning at Khan
Academy Megan and so Megan will join us
and this will be a great chance and
everyone can ask questions students can
ask questions parents and teachers but
especially we're gonna start for some of
the questions from parents and teachers
on how do you get set up how do you look
at student dashboards what are best
practices things like that and as I wait
for making to get on I will give a few
more announcements above and beyond this
live stream at Khan Academy we're trying
to see what other supports can we give
you so yesterday was the first time that
we ran a virtual classroom for algebra
students so these are students in
algebra 1 or algebra 2 and this was at
10 a.m. Pacific we did it yesterday and
we were able to cover some examples
answer questions about systems of
equations tomorrow we're going to be
doing again though there you see you can
see an example of what it looks like we
actually it really did feel like a
classroom and I think there was about a
thousand students that's if we're all
experimenting with new things and I was
I was able to answer a lot of the
students questions tomorrow we're gonna
do it again we got a lot of positive
feedback from it so on Thursday at once
again 10 a.m. Pacific and tomorrow's
topic is actually going to be factoring
and graphing quadratics and we're going
that it's not just me giving a lecture
we're gonna give you a problem to work
on for students to work on they're gonna
be able to fill out surveys on what they
think the answer is they're gonna be
able to vote on questions for me to
answer so we're gonna try to make it
feel as much like a live interactive
classroom as possible so with that I'd
love to bring on Meghan and we could
start answering some questions Meghan
are you there oh hey hi falynn hi
everyone how are you good good good and
maybe a good place to start I just
talked about the algebra 1 and algebra 2
virtual classrooms but we're also
leading webinars for teachers and
parents if you could tell us a little
bit about those absolutely Sal so we
know that this is a pretty chaotic time
for everyone students parents teachers
and we are trying to offer opportunities
for parents and teachers as well as
students to ask their questions and find
a space where they can share some of the
things
going through their heads right now and
how we might be able to best support
them through this transition and so over
the past couple weeks we've had a couple
of webinars around getting started on
Khan Academy as both a parent and a
teacher and then we've ran one last
Friday on tips for effective remote
teaching and learning and the recordings
for all of those are available on the
site along with some supporting
resources and coming up in the next
couple of days this afternoon we have
office hours again for teachers to get
their questions answered by some of our
ambassadors are really exceptional you
know using beauty and and then we have
another webinar tomorrow from one of our
ambassadors talking about some of the
best ways for teachers to get effective
results using Khan Academy and keep an
eye Oh we'll be looking to add another
parent webinar next week
to help parents get started with both
Khan Academy and Khan Academy kids
awesome thanks Megan and maybe just a
starting question that we've gotten many
versions of what I'm about to ask you
but a lot of teachers and parents are
just feeling a little overwhelmed
schools closed with not a lot of notice
not a lot of planning this is a new
frontier for all of us for you know
speaking to a teacher and and to some
degree a parent now who is feeling
overwhelmed how should they even think
about remote learning and what steps
might they wanted to take I think that's
a really key point Sal is that a lot of
people are feeling overwhelmed and there
wasn't a lot of time for preparation and
teachers in particulars are preparers I
was a classroom teacher for nine years
and I couldn't imagine the shock of
transitioning from being in the
classroom brick-and-mortar space with my
students to jumpin fully remote so
quickly and I think one thing that I've
heard from a lot of teachers and a lot
of parents is take a deep breath it's
not the expectation that you are going
to cover everything you could cover in
your classroom right now it's really
important to cut yourself and your
students some slack and just know that
the fact that you are taking endeavor of
getting them active
learning and focusing on some key
concepts is really great and that you're
taking time to embrace kind of the
emotional impact for both you as a
parent or a teacher and your students
and building in some time into your time
with students to be able to reflect with
them and you know take some time as as
you shared in some of those schedules
take some time to reflect on what's
going on right now and incorporate that
into the learning experience and I'd say
the other piece that I would really
really focus on is communication I fear
sometimes that working remotely with
students and teachers gives the illusion
that there's less need to communicate
but in fact we really need more
communication right now and taking the
time to either connect live with
students or send a message the students
you know finding opportunities to create
that human connection even if you're not
in the same physical space is so
important right now and I'm getting a
question here from Debbie Charlton who's
actually one of the the khan academy
teacher ambassadors and debbie asking
you know Debbie how can you assign conte
content to specific students based on
what they have not worked on yet but
others may have so we have the situation
where I guess always kids might be a
different levels might be working at
different things and to some degree we
support that but how does a teacher
maybe assign that or or should they
assign that how do you think about that
yeah I think it's a good question that
we think about you know not just in this
time but especially now where you have
the additional challenge of not being
able to see that student so I think what
is really great about Khan Academy is
the ability to assign these broad
mastery goals so when we think about
what are the students trying to
accomplish for the year are they trying
to you know work on algebra 1 are they
trying to complete third-grade math or
maybe high school biology our mastery
extends beyond math and so I think
starting with that mastery goal which
allows students to work at their own
time and pace and helps them identify
areas of opportunity and we have some
resources right on the site right from
that banner when you get to Khan Academy
that will
connect you and how to set up a mastery
goal and so any teacher could leverage
that is a really good starting point and
then once you're able to see students
progress and we see maybe after three to
five sessions I'm working towards that
master goal you're the teacher reporting
will allow teachers to identify growth
opportunities so skills that students
might need additional support with and
from there there's an assign button and
teachers can for individual students
small groups of students or the entire
class with outlined exercises to
identify and support learning in that
gap area so the short version is
assigned a mastery goal and use the data
to make supporting assignments and we
have again we have some resources right
on our website that walk teachers
through this and some specifically to
support in that remote learning
situation and we have another kind of
related question also from Debbie which
is a question I think many teachers are
asking which is how does it work with
Google classroom we just talked about
assignments and to what degree should
you and kids are at different levels but
what support or integration do we or
don't we have with Google classroom or
how would you use it it's a good
question and we do integrate with Google
classroom and the best thing about that
is that as we know a lot of teachers are
establishing their classrooms on Khan
Academy now and as a teacher I can
empathize with the setup and frosting
and getting to norms with students and
if your students are already comfortable
with Google classroom you can connect
Google classroom directly to Khan
Academy you don't have to add a new
roster you don't have to create a new
class you can as you set up your class
there's an option that says connect with
Google classroom and it will import your
roster directly and so in a time where
students are already having to learn so
many new tools and we want them to focus
right more on learning the content than
learning new technology by integrating
Khan Academy with your Google classroom
account students can access that in the
same way they've already be using it so
you're taking a step of stress off of
you and off of your students awesome and
then we're getting a lot of question
here one of them this is from sonal Zhu
tele as a parent where to start on Khan
Academy as a roadmap for seventh grader
are there live classes Khan Academy's
plan offer I could take maybe take a
first stab at that one so as many of
y'all know we published schedules for
students of different age categories and
so we do have one that a 7th grader
would fall in I think one of the things
we are thinking about is can we start
especially now that it looks like some
of the school closures might be longer
and maybe go through the summer we are
we are thinking about maybe we could
create some goals or learning plans for
students but those haven't been released
yet we're gonna try to we're trying to
do everything we can with the resources
we have in terms of live classes these
live straight these webinars these uh I
guess we could these classrooms we're
doing we started with algebra this is
really just an experiment we started the
first one yesterday we're gonna do
another one tomorrow and we're going to
see where this goes
what capabilities we have on our side to
do more and more but I you know I don't
want to jump the gun on it because we
are very resource constrained right now
but I would love to figure out ways to
support middle school students as well
algebra we picked because that's a major
area that a lotta that's that's
foundational for a lot of folks but
obviously so is so is middle school math
pre-algebra and obviously not just math
there's other subjects as well that
might be interesting let's see we have a
question from from Facebook so it says
IQ actually just got modified from Laura
Hall our school wants us to filter
everything through Google classroom so
it's more of a one-stop shop I'd love to
be able to link their assignment
straight to Google from Khan any chance
that could be available that's
essentially very similar to what you had
just answered and the simple answer is
yes so I will link the rosters currently
the assignments don't show up directly
in Google classroom when we know that's
a common ask for teachers we've heard
that even prior to this remote learning
transition and we we I know there's a
lot going on right now and that would be
a really helpful piece for teachers we
do find that the connecting with Google
classroom allows the roster to be you
know brought in really easily and that
student
can login to Khan Academy simply by
using google single sign-on and they'll
see their assignments the moment they
log in right on their learner homepage
so that way students don't have to go
digging around for that so while it's
not a direct connection to posting the
assignments in Google classroom it does
really become lowlich for the students
right now thanks Megan so let's see
there's a couple of questions here these
go a little bit these are more student
facing questions but we could we could
try to answer a couple of these really
quick let's see from YouTube Cara's
Alexander says how's kind of kind of me
helping out with AP exams well cars
we've had content for many of the core
AP exams even before this crisis hit AP
Calculus AP stats ap biology chemistry
physics micro macroeconomics CS
principles American history civics in
government I think I got all of them I
might be Oh an art history I think I got
all of them so we've always had that
content that you can learn at your own
time and pace use the unit test use the
course challenges the master challenges
to make sure that you've really digested
a lot of that material and even before
this crisis hit historically as we've
gone into AP exams we have tried to run
some webinars and live streams for
students at write when they're trying to
prepare and so we're going to try to
explore that type of thing for this year
as well so let's see other questions on
YouTube courageous cuber says is it okay
for me to study physics in seventh grade
my two cents yeah if you're ready to
study physics in seventh grade
no one should stop you that's great and
you know what I would say is to do
physics on Khan Academy we have the
algebra based physics you you should
definitely know the basics of algebra I
know the basics of quadratics things
like parabola is factoring quadratics
and know the basics of trigonometry
things like sine cosine tangent if you
know those things you actually are ready
for physics high school level physics
and if you don't know those things you
actually could jump in and learn those
units those particular units and
actually you'll be you'll have the math
background to engage on the physics side
let's see other questions
for we have well astro jaden on youtube
pretty big question what was the origin
of Khan Academy how did you come up with
the idea of creating a nonprofit
organization so I'll answer it as
concisely as I can because I've been
known to talk about this for how many of
y'all know it started as a project with
my family members and I kept thinking
what more tools could I make for my
family members it's eerily similar to
the situation we're in now where we're
just like okay there's a big need what
tools can we create and then how can we
make it serve the needs of more and more
people but this was back with me and one
cousin and then more word got around my
family free tutoring what's going on
myself with many folks and so I started
writing the exercises on Khan Academy an
early version that was what Khan Academy
was initially about and it was a friend
that recommended I make videos to
supplement those exercises and I thought
that I was treated as a silly idea as
you know I often say you know I said
YouTube is for cats playing piano but I
had already idea that wasn't my idea
gave it a shot and that took on a life
of its own and then by 2009-2010 and or
hundreds of thousands of people using it
I had trouble focusing on my day job
which was really being a I was an
analyst at an investment firm and so I
sat on my wife who said hey maybe we
should start this off as a nonprofit
hopefully I'll find people who could
donate and I took the plunge and the
whole reason I wanted to do is a
not-for-profit I do live in Silicon
Valley people were offering to fund it
as a for-profit business and it just you
know for this particular role in society
it felt like the wrong thing to do
there's nothing wrong with for-profit
businesses but for something in
education where you don't want to make
it based on who has the ability to pay
you want to help level the playing field
you want to have universal access if
someone wants to learn there should be
no frictions to it that was the point
and you know we set up this mission free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere and it was somewhat delusional
eleven years ago for a guy operating out
of a walk-in closet but over the last
ten years with the help of this really
incredible team at Khan Academy many
many thousands of people who've donated
to this effort and we need more help
we've been able to make I think a bit of
a dent and and really scale to a lot of
folks and you know I think this whole
school
for crisis due to cope in nineteen
highlights I think the importance of us
existing the work that this team has
been able to do and and why it was
important that we're not-for-profit
because there's a lot going on in that
tech and a lot of people doing really
great things but in this time of school
closures you need something that is
universally accessible and part of that
is it has to be free and that's where
we're fairly unique and you know truly
free
so no shady stuff with ads no kind of
free but then there might be some
payment for better things no we'll sell
your data type of free none of that
truly free and not doing anything shady
shady with data that's important right
now you have to have a breadth and depth
of subjects we have gone into many many
subjects and in many areas where there
might not be a business model so other
EdTech players haven't gone there but
and so that's why we're able to go from
early learning through elementary middle
high school core of college in math
reading writing sciences etc and and and
yeah it has to have a kind of more
people it has to because of its
nonprofit nature it brings more people
to the effort that's why we're able to
have forty translated versions of Khan
Academy most of which are done by
volunteers around the world so thanks
for the question I give the the heck
could talking more about it if folks if
folks are interested so let's see other
other questions that we're getting so
see if I'm using and and this is from
Facebook Amy asked if I'm using Khan
Academy for high school seniors for a
high school senior school year what
ground rules do I want to set make
anyone take a take a stab at that I
could I might have some ideas although I
haven't raised high school seniors just
yet we had a couple of ideas from the
webinar the other day that I think we're
you know maybe something teachers are
comfortable with but might not put into
this framing of remote learning usually
at the beginning of the year a teacher
will set classroom norms for their
students and what we find to be most
effective is including your students in
that conversation about classroom norms
you know things like raising your hand
and or you know what process for you
know when you're gonna use Chromebooks
in the classroom the same type of things
apply to remote learning so you have to
re-establish norms with your students
about what your expectations are and
what behaviors are you know appropriate
for when you're having you know a remote
learning session and so if you're
thinking about seniors and I taught high
school science so I can relate to your
seniors for sure
I would think about you know taking time
to set learning norms and you know
remote classroom norms with your seniors
what are the best practices for your
students and for your new classroom
setup and then by including your
students in that conversation they're
more likely to hold each other
accountable and follow those rules
because they felt like they were a part
of the process and so being able to
establish those norms for you and your
students makes everyone feel a little
bit more comfortable in the space Salim
chair you had something to add on to
that as well no I think that's exactly
right you know this is a time especially
for high school seniors where you know
III wrote about it in one world
schoolhouse that a lot of what we call
teenage angst I believe actually comes
from in most of human history by the
time someone was 13 or 14 years old they
were kind of proto adults and they were
given significant responsibilities in
most of human history
for for other people for their clan for
their tribe and in modern society for 13
14 15 you know teenagers we don't give
them a lot of responsibility beyond
themselves we don't we we we treat them
oftentimes like children and I think
especially for high school seniors as
you mentioned Megan the more agency and
ownership we can give and it's authentic
they feel like oh they they do have a
voice in it they're setting ground rules
for themselves I have taught you know we
have a little Lab School downstairs from
our offices and I've taught high school
seniors and I've actually found that
when you say hey what norms should you
know if I told them hey no one can do
this or you can't use chat this way or
you can't talk while I'm talking you
know then they'll rebel but if I say
what norms do you want to have and how
will you enforce it as a group I've seen
I've seen kids as young as 12
13 step up to that challenge and
actually come up with better and
stricter norms that they're willing to
enforce then I would have put on them
and I think that's definitely true of
high school seniors and especially in
this time that everyone's in their own
walk-in closet so to speak everyone's
socially distance it's even more
important to rely on their individual
agency so that makes a ton of sense with
what you said Megan so let's see there's
a question from Facebook by Judy can
students take retake quizzes and test as
many times as they want or can I put a
limit to it I'll take a first a first
attempt at it so the simple answer is
yes they can take quizzes and tests as
many times as they want and you know
that's an actually an important
principle that we wanted at Khan Academy
it actually would've been a lot easier
for us to just make quizzes that you
take once and you're done and that's
just your score but we're strong
believers in mastery learning that if
you get an 80% on something that
shouldn't be like your permanent state
for the rest of your life that you're a
C student in factoring quadratics or
photosynthesis that you should have as
many attempts as you need to take it but
every time you take it it's actually
going to be a different quiz so we've
actually written many many many items
more than you most people probably
realize to be able to have that
capability so we want students to say oh
I got a 70% that time let me take
another attempt and see if I can improve
my score or maybe I can go try to learn
a little better and then try to improve
my score so I guess there might be
situations although yeah in general we
favor kids trying to take as many times
as possible make it any any any things
to add to that sure one thing I'll add
that teachers find useful while we do
and I would absolutely agree with Sal
but we do encourage students to try and
try again as many people will say you
know failure even if you don't do well
the first time does not mean failing
it's just an opportunity to try again
and you know learn something more when
we think about teachers oh and they want
to see how students are progressing if
you choose to make a quiz an assignment
you do have the opportunity to look at
how students answer questions on their
first attempt and their last attempt so
if you want to see how they did do that
first time out the gate you can look
specifically at those answers in our
teacher reports
and then look at where they ended up so
you can see their progress over time and
if you wanted a snapshot of their first
attempt you have access to that data but
we do want to continue to encourage
students to learn and grow and so
exactly what cell said there is no you
know mechanism by which to limit the
attempts that they make but you as a
teacher can still see that information
so it's in some cases it's the best of
both worlds
Thanks making us super helpful let's see
we have more questions here we have a
question this is from YouTube by alga
marble racer Sal how do you make money
from Khan Academy it is nonprofit that's
a good question and when we think about
huh so the simple answer in through
those who you don't know you know a lot
of people say well isn't you know isn't
Google nonprofit because it's free and
free and not don't mean the same thing
although Khan Academy is both of those
things a lot of for-profit companies in
Google they've actually been great
supporters of Khan Academy and actually
even in the early days that they were
one of our first funders you know
they're able to offer their services
free but they make money in other ways
through ads or other types of things
what makes a non-profit or for-profit
different is Google is owned by
shareholders they have owners of the
company if you go by some Google stock
you are one of those owners of of Google
Khan Academy has no ownership I I have
no ownership in Khan Academy or I have
as much ownership as anyone listening
does we all it's a it's a public good
and the way that I and the whole team
here live is that we do get salaries
from Khan Academy and then that is
governed by a board so no one owns Khan
Academy there's a Board of Directors the
board is made up of some of those folks
are representative of some of the major
donors to Khan Academy some of them are
other people who are experts in
education or in other fields and they're
the ones that govern and you know they
can hire or fire me they set my salary
and similarly they set the budget for
the whole organization so we take we
take salaries now where does that money
come from it comes from philanthropic
donations and you know every time I talk
about the budget of Khan Academy
me I get a little bit of a cortisol
boost of stress because it's a large
budget but it's small compared to the
impact that it's having a Khan Academy's
budget is the budget of a large high
school it's about sixty million dollars
a year but we impact probably this year
hundreds of millions of students every
year in past years you know we've had on
the order of 15 16 17 18 million
students come every month and that's
been growing and over the last couple
weeks that's been growing 2x and 3x and
so we do need that support we do need
those donations from corporations from
individuals is as small as you can see
on the screen is $3.00 makes a
difference or us and so if you're in a
position to benefit from Khan Academy
and support it so that other people can
benefit from Khan Academy please please
do so we really appreciate that so other
questions a one from YouTube teacher
question comes from Catherine Carey if
we want a supplement learning with Khan
Academy with our own materials so
students can see some of us what is the
best way to deliver our content
electronically I could throw a few ideas
and I'm curious what Megan thinks one
thing that we've been encouraging with
the schedules especially at this time of
social distancing is kids can work
asynchronously on something like Khan
Academy and it would be amazing if
teachers can organize video conferences
using hangout using Skype hey you know
zoom so that they can answer questions
do things analogous to what we've been
doing with some of these alive
classrooms that we've been doing but
obviously you could do it with your
students there's also a world where you
can create materials you know yourself
at a whiteboard or use a digital tablet
the way I have here at Khan Academy to
create videos I know my children's
school is doing that and so you know
there's a lot of work that that my kids
are doing that you know like a writing
assignment so they're teachers making a
video putting it on their cue using the
learning management system so it could
be Google classroom or something else so
that the students know okay here's my
checklist for the day oh I got to watch
a video by Mickey one of my one of my
son's teachers he's you know he watches
the video by Mickey Mickey says
something about how do you analyze
certain forms of text here's the
assignment then he does it then he
submits it on
the LMS but it would be really cool what
I've been seeing some really incredible
teachers doing even at my own children's
school is they've been having touch
points roughly at least once a day with
students so that they can ask questions
they can understand how to navigate
things I may get any other ideas there I
would you know huge hugely hugely
endorsed everything you just said
because as you mentioned right in this
time of social distancing having that
social experience is so much more vital
to students lives every day right
they're used to being around each other
and leaning on their teacher you know to
share parts of their day or to ask
questions so I think everything you
mentioned is really wonderful and if
teachers have the opportunity I do like
to recommend that along with the live
experience make sure that it can be
recorded because we know that students
just as much as adults are struggling
with schedules right now so maybe they
are responsible for watching and younger
siblings or they only have access to a
device later out of the day so that if
you are going to connect I try and make
a recording as well so that all of your
students have access to that material
the other piece I might recommend is
that if you are making your own
assignments as well if you can do them
in something like Google Docs or Google
Sites and allow students to leave
comments for each other maybe one of
those reflection activities that you
know Sal you've offered in our daily
schedules and so that students can leave
really positive reinforcing comments for
each other so that they're still
connecting beyond you know just that one
moment that's a great idea I didn't
thought about that you know we're not on
our schedules we suggested maybe
journaling but there might be a world
where you do like collective journaling
where everyone has a little section and
and not only do you write yourself but
you can see how everyone else's day is
and how they can think about it how they
comment I love I love that idea Megan so
time flies when you're having fun so far
really create questions here that I wish
I could get to but the good thing is
we're doing this every day so come back
tomorrow 12 p.m. Pacific time 3 p.m.
Eastern or whatever time zone you you
you might be in and thanks for joining
thanks Megan for joining you know as I
say every day these live streams are way
for us to stay connected and this time
of social distancing and the silver
lining through this crisis that we're
all going through is that we're all
going through this together and I get a
lot of energy doing this I'm sure I
speak for Megan and the entire Khan
Academy team it's really an honor for us
to be of service in this time of need
and we want to do everything possible
for every teacher listening every parent
teacher every parent listening every
student listening to make sure you feel
supported and you feel connected thank
you so much and see you tomorrow
you